and the latest news in a major positive  pandemic milestone  folks have good news everybody is  eligible as of today  to get the vaccine you have enough of it  you need to be protected so this morning  president biden announced every american  aged 16 and older is now eligible to get  the coronavirus vaccine  the president is urging you to get  vaccinated not only for yourself  but for your family so far more than 131  million americans have received at least  one  dose meanwhile though new coveted  infections are still rising  and use of the johnson and johnson  vaccine is still paused however that  single dose  shot is expected to make its return  later this week one of the possibilities  would be to bring them back  but to do it with some form of  restriction  or some form of warning dr anthony fauci  there a cdc centers for disease control  advisory committee meets on friday  to discuss the johnson johnson vaccine